alors à quel point ces variants qui
apparaissent aussi au japon et en
afrique du sud
sont ils plus dangereux j'en parle avec
la docteur nathalie grandvaux la
directrice du laboratoire de recherche
sur la réponse de l'autre aux infections
virales au chum
bonsoir d'autres grands vont bon soir
madame galipeau alors c'est le variant
britannique y détecter chez nous
qu'est-ce qu'on lançait de ce variant
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire sur ce variant qui est
celui que vous avez cités qu'on connaît
le mieux c'est qui se transmet en fait
qu'on le retrouve se propager dans la
population beaucoup plus rapidement que
le variant habituel qui qui d'habitude
circulent ici donc sa propagation est
beaucoup plus rapide c'est ce qu'on sait
actuelle donc il est plus contagieuse
que ça veut dire qu'il est plus
dangereux côté pour l'instant les
données disponibles qui sont
majoritairement des données
épidémiologiques donc de suivi de la
population n'indique pas que la maladie
associée à ce variant soit plus sévère
par contre qu'on peut ce qu'il faut pas
éliminer de l'équation si je peux dire
c'est que comme il se propage plus et on
voit sur les courbes de deux nombres de
cas au royaume uni en irlande que ça se
propage vraiment très très vite on va
avoir plus de cas dans dans ses dents
lorsque ce variant la se propage et donc
ultime mans on s'attend malheureusement
à avoir beaucoup plus d'hospitalisations
est beaucoup plus probablement de décès
à la france donc en boule et il est
finalement plus dangereux à cause de ça
bon il ya quelques cas en ontario au
québec il ya eu un premier cas qui a été
détecté en décembre dernier est-ce que
ça ça vous préoccupe
ça me préoccupe pas encore au point de
vouloir changer les choses radicalement
parce que on a on est peut-être
peut-être je dis bien un peu chanceux
parce qu'on a un timing qui est qu' on a
commencé à voir ce variant la ici au
moment où on finalement reconfirmer donc
avec un peu de chance on va maîtriser sa
propagation avec toutes les nouvelles
mesures qui sont en place depuis le 17
décembre est en fait il faut absolument
maintenir ses mesures
dans le contexte de prévenir la
propagation de ce variant qui est
probablement la plus qu'un cas
qu'on a des pistes est pour le moment et
comment est ce qu on les détecte ces
variants en fait pour détecter les
variants il faut faire une séquence en
faire obtenir l'information génétique du
virus en fait comme quand on fait une
génétique sur un être humain pour
connaître des mutations pour des
maladies génétiques mais on fait la même
chose sur les virus ont séquence en fait
son génome et ça on le fait c'est une
procédure quand même relativement
coûteuse et qui prend du temps mais
c'est le seul mais le seul moyen pour le
moment de savoir si ces variantes sont
présents notamment la question qu'on se
pose c'est qu'il ya des vaccins qu'on
utilise actuellement et est ce qu'ils
sont efficaces et vaccin là contre ces
nouveaux variants ou pas bien entendu
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose puis à plusieurs laboratoires au
monde qui qui se posent cette question
et qui ont les outils pour y répondre et
on commence à avoir les premières
données expérimentales qui sont je
dirais assez rassurantes pour montrer
que finalement les anticorps qui sont
présents chez des patients qui ont eu
qui ont eu la qu'ovide en fait ou qui
ont eu le vaccin maintenant on peut le
faire avec les patients qui ont reçu les
premières doses de vaccin
en fait on se rend compte qu'ils ont une
efficacité contre le variant en tout cas
de celui du royaume uni
donc c'est pas complet c'est encore
préliminaires mais c'est très
encourageant et les analyses les
modélisations qu'on peut faire suggère
que les deux vaccins que ce soit solide
face the road moderna vont fonctionner
contre ce variant a priori le problème
c'est peut-être que même avec la
vaccination en cours
l'om est dit qu'il sera pas possible
d'atteindre l'immunité collective quand
j'avais 19 ans en 2021
alors quoi il va falloir être patient
écoutez c'est sûr que pour l'instant
c'est une course contre la montre entre
la propagation du virus et
l'immunisation de la population vous le
voyez comme le calendrier comme vous
parliez j'ai aussi de vaccination ne va
pas aussi vite qu on aimerait il faut
produire ces vaccins les ailes et les
livrer en fait et puis les donner aux
patients donc c'est sûr que moi je
dirais que je suis optimiste si on a
d'autres vaccins qui arrivent sur le
marché par exemple on devrait avoir des
nouvelles d'ici peu du vaccin de johnson
& johnson où ils ont sp en parallèle
deux doses puis une dose si on arrivait
avec un vaccin qui a qu'une seule dose
on gagnerait beaucoup en efficacité de
d'immunisation donc les prochains
vaccins vont aider beaucoup à accélérer
ce qu'elle en prix oui alors il va
falloir aussi bien sûr être très
vigilant en termes de mesures sanitaires
d'autres grandvaux merci beaucoup merci
à vous et bonne soirée